je suis chanteur d'opéra ténor cette
exotique et d'ailleurs par exemple quand
je dis ça bien dans un dîner les gens
ouvrent grand les yeux
je ne sais pas s'il me prennent pour un
fou ou s'ils sont fascinés en tout cas
généralement il y en a un ou une qui va
me demander bain dans quel chorale je
chante alors ça tend un peu la
conversation
et puis après on discute et puis arrive
un moment où finalement il ya quelle île
il ya quelqu'un qui va me demander quel
est mon vrai métier
je suis désolé pour un début de top
c'est n'importe quoi c'est oui c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi parce que bon je
pensais que c'est une urgence mais c'est
ma femme qui me quittes
bon voilà elle s'en va il part avec
notre banquier
qu'est ce qu'elle dit oui avec lui avec
le banquier pourrons parler de musique
parce qu'il faut dire que ma femme elle
et moi on parlait surtout de d'argent
non non non si nos demandes
pour une chypre un sauna la coiffure
rasta
howard est à katara mono domo
disco
mon coeur se brise ma femme me quitter
moi moi moi je chante au pas de gaieté
de coeur non mais quelque chose en moi
chante ou plus exactement quelque chose
en moi si je sait y faire appel prend le
relais et chante quoi qu'il arrive je
suis un interprète
l'interprétation c'est mon métier mon
rôle à moi c'est de partager avec un
public des sons une histoire des
émotions mais pas mes propres émotions
pas ma propre histoire non moi je suis
au service d'un auteur d'un compositeur
et puis d'un personnage interprété c'est
me mettre au service de quelque chose
qui est plus grand que moi quelque chose
qui existe en dehors de moi qui existent
avant moi mais qui là maintenant tout de
suite devant vous a besoin de moi pour
exister interprété c'est comme une
énergie qui vous transcende joffre avoir
quelque chose de moi dont je n'ai même
pas forcément conscience la dîmière de
jankélévitch le très célèbre musicologue
et philosophe du début du xxème siècle
né à bourges pas si loin que ça
jankélévitch en parlant de cette énergie
transcendante il nous disait que c'était
le je-ne-sais-quoi et puis surtout il a
ajouté que derrière ce je ne sais quoi
il n'y avait aucune magie il y avait
simplement du travail de l'apprentissage
d'ailleurs dans la vie professionnelle
dans le monde de l'entreprise ou même
dans votre vie privée dans votre vie
familiale vous et nous nous créons des
projets nous inventons des projets nous
rêvons un futur mais passé ce moment de
la création
eh bien ces projets il faut les
présenter devant les autres devant nos
collaborateurs devant nos clients devant
nos amis nos parents et puis même des
fois devant notre bon pied alors là on
veut faire partager nos convictions
on veut faire partager notre
enthousiasme enfin bref on veut
convaincre donc tout projet a besoin du
véhicule
de l'interprétation pour toucher un
public c'est le premier passage à l'acte
c'est l'épreuve du feu dont peut
dépendre l'avenir du projet et
éventuellement une partie de notre
propre avenir
ton pour nos primes si psa elle a trois
frères d'asta
moore
l'ispa
ça
comme tout à l'heure c'était la musique
de puccini le début du deuxième aire de
calaf dans l'opéra turandot tu opéra
d'ailleurs que puccini n'a pas pu
terminer en 1924 pour cause de décès bon
c'était la musique de puccini mais
l'effet produit sur vous n'a pas été le
même
la première chose qui a changé c'était
mon engagement mon absence d'engagement
j'ai récité g and honey des sons des
mots sans grande conviction
mais mon interprétation vous a touché
différemment je n'étais pas là en fait
donc mon premier objectif qu'elle est il
est là il est clair c'est d'oser
investir mon corps dawes et habiter mon
corps et partant de la dose est habité
ce lieu avec mon corps alors
concrètement avant de rentrer sur cette
scène eh bien je dois savoir avec
précision où est ma place devant vous et
puis alors ma place je ne fais que la
rejoindre et là c'est déjà un premier
objectif qui est atteint en fait si je
sais où je vais la question du comment
givet ne se pose quasiment plus et puis
une fois que je suis là et bien cette
place je la fais mienne je prends
contact avec le sol de cette scène et
puis la façon la plus simple la plus
efficace la plus naturelle vu que je
suis un bipède et que depuis newton je
sais que je suis soumis à la loi de la
pesanteur et bien la façon la plus
simple pour prendre contact avec le sol
de cette scène et bien c'est d'oser
respirer profondément je pose mes pieds
sur le sol et je respire profondément
j'aspire le sol sous mes pieds
tiens tu n'es puisque nous sommes
ensemble ce soir et bien aux ont
ensemble
vous pouvez par exemple décoller un
petit peu le dos du dossier de vos
chaises
soyez joueur
et puis merci ça m'aide décoller un peu
votre dos posez vos pieds sur le sol
sentait le sol avec la plante de vos
pieds
et puis là comme des enfants n'ayez pas
peur aspiré le sol en dessous par la
plante de vos pieds
et puis ce sol laisser le monte dans vos
filles dans vos mollets dans vos genoux
dans vos cuisses je sais tu voulais
mettre dans le bon ordre dans votre
bassin dans votre ventre
et puis là ça arrive dans la poitrine
non seulement c'est bon mais ça vous
donne confiance
ça vous donne de la force et c'est le
premier acte le premier fut la première
phase de l'incarnation
alors moi je suis là devant vous par ma
posture par mon souffle j'ai une base
solide et bien je peux commencer à
penser agir
je peux commencer à rêver de conquérir
mon public
et bien vous allez rire mais la méthode
la plus exceptionnelle pour réussir ce
défi de l'action en marche et bien c'est
le lâcher prise
la tempête émotionnels provoqués par ma
femme et mon ex banquier ou l' inverse
eh bien elle est confinée là dans une
pièce à part moi je suis là addex le
philosophe suisse
donc a priori pas né à bourges comme
jankélévitch quoique le philosophe
suisse alexandre jollien se lâcher prise
ils appellent ça l'abandon je ne me
rétracte pas sur mes difficultés je ne
ressasse pas au contraire jemappes orb
dans l'instant présent pour moi
musiciens ça veut dire que je peux
m'abandonner à la musique donc à ce
moment là mon intention elle n'est plus
de faire de la musique mais elle est
d'être la musique
et puis grâce à cet abandon à se lâcher
prise
je vais pouvoir rentrer en cohérence en
cohérence avec le discours musical
parce que je peux investir un autre
univers bien imaginer nous sommes en
chine à pékin devant les murs de la cité
interdite
la nuit étoilée recours
or la cité interdite et puis on a un peu
cette brise qui nous glace les os et
puis là on aperçoit à calaf cal a filé
seul calaf il est fou amoureux de tueur
en dot tu rentres d'autres c'est la
fille de l'empereur de chine
rien que ça et calaf pour avoir le droit
d'épouser tueur en dot hill a accepté de
répondre à trois énigmes
il faut dire qu'avant lui il ya beaucoup
d'hommes qui ont perdu la vie qui ont
perdu la tête
pour avoir essayé de répondre à ces
trois énigmes mais lui qu'à la ville a
relevé le défi et puis alors comme gage
supplémentaire de son amour pour tueur
en dot et bien il remet une nouvelle
fois sa vie entre ses mains et lui dit
si demain matin quand le jour se lève
tu as réussi à percer le mystère de mon
nom eh bien tu feras de moi ce que tu
voudras mais si demain à l'aube nouvelle
mon nombre est toujours secret pour toi
et bien tu seras mienne alors qu'à la
fin il est là devant les murs de la cité
interdite et puis il va chanter
et puis le pan saturn lot qui est seul
dans le froid de la chambre de son
palais impérial
et puis elle regarde les étoiles qui
tremble d'amour et d'espérance
et puis il lui dit mon mystère est resté
enfermé en moi mais l année au lycée
audouin mon nom personne ne le saura
monomanie gijón sabla non non non non
sur ta bouche je le dirai aux attentes
oh quand la lumière resplendira qua none
à l'ofce sparano
et bien quand je commence à chanter ses
phrases musicales
je ne peux pas interrompre le geste de
la musique de la même façon que quand je
suis rentré sur cette scène et que je
savais où j'allais et bien par mon
travail par mon étude de la partition
je dois respecter le sens je dois
respecter la direction de chaque phrase
musicale et donc de la musique dans son
entier alors eh bien je peux m'absorbe
est dans le moment je peux m'abandonner
à la musique
et puis chaque phrase par son sens sa
direction va me mener à la phrase
suivante
j'entre en cohérence voilà mes amis sur
gameblog
en quoi mal à l'autre
et puis vous voyez avec ce lâcher prise
qui donne de la cohérence à mon discours
bien c'est génial même les silences ne
sont pas effrayants souvenez-vous au
début de l'ère kadhafi chante mais son
nom
à il répète personne ne dort nessun
dorma parce que tu rentres note elle
elle veut savoir comment elles comment
il s'appelle donc elle a envoyé dans
toute la ville de pékin ses sbires qui
sont aux aguets qui sont fébriles et
bien cette tension cette fébrilité elle
vit dans le silence
elle est décrite dans le silence le
silence vous l'avez aussi après votre
discours à la fin de la musique
sacha guitry d'ailleurs ou en tout cas
on prête à sacha guitry de nous avoir
dit que le silence après la musique de
mozart c'est encore la musique de mozart
mais le silence
il existe aussi avant je prenne la
parole avant que je chante et là non
plus ce n'est pas du vide c'est le
moment où je puise la force en moi dans
le sol sous mes pieds pour donner
naissance à la phrase musicale chantée
par les c'est un geste elle ce geste il
prend naissance dans mon inspiration
et puis si j'ai travaillé ma partition
mon projet avec soin eh bien il est
énorme d'observer combien j'inspire plus
que seulement de l'air dans le silence
de ma respiration la musique elle se
nourrit du silence se lâcher prise cet
abandon
ils me permettent de rentrer en
cohérence de donner de la cohérence à
mon discours musical pour ce qui me
concerne mais également ils donnent de
la justesse à mon propos
mes mots mais son sommes plus juste et
il sonne plus juste dans tous les sens
du terme et il somme plus juste parce
que je ne cherche pas à plaquer mes
propres émotions sur les émotions de la
musique ou du compositeur non je
m'efface derrière mon projet je ne suis
pas dans un mouvement de séduction mais
je suis dans un mouvement sincère et
profond ce mouvement profond qui
sous-tend la phrase musicale
nous les musiciens on l'appelle le
phrasé c'est l'énergie propre à la
musique c'est la musique dans la musique
alors je sais où je vais je suis un
carnet j'ai travaillé avec le plus soin
possible mon projet je laisse mon
imagination précédé le champ je m'offre
également en faisant cela la possibilité
de donner de la sincérité à mon propos
et la sincérité et bien nous connecte à
c'était un sel à cette humanité qui
existent au fond de chacun d'entre nous
alors pour conclure vous me direz mais
moi je vous dis en tout cas pourquoi
tout ça pourquoi toute cette stratégie
cette énergie par conscience
professionnelle
par amour du travail bien fait par amour
de la musique par amour de l'opéra bah
oui oui évidemment bien sûr mais pas que
et je dirais même il me semble que la
première raison c'est pour se relier aux
autres pour me relier à vous parce que
si je suis chanteur si je suis chanteur
d'opéra et souvent je suis seul en scène
je n'existe pas tout seul jeu au service
d'un compositeur je suis là pour un
public
je n'existe que dans une chaîne
collective chacun d'entre nous qu'on
présente un projet une idée un bilan
vous l'aurez compris qu'on donne des
cours devant des élèves on n'existe que
dans cette chaîne humaine tout ce qu'on
fait n'a de sens que par rapport aux
autres alors savoir où on va s'incarner
ne pas vouloir remplir à tout prix
laisser vivre le silence travailler son
projet se relier aux autres
tout cela ce sont des clés pour nous
donner confiance en nous pour nous
donner confiance dans les autres et puis
pour nous donner confiance dans notre
projet tient de projets qu'à la finale
avait un lui épousé la fille de
l'empereur de chine etc à la fille la
confiance il sait que deux à l'aube qui
va se lever le lendemain et bien la nuit
va se dissiper les étoiles vont remonter
dans le ciel
et lui il vaincra mono
tout le monde doit test
allah
à vincenzo
or une seule ville
merci oui merci
mais à votre tour soyez les dignes
interprète de vos projets soyez les
dignes interprète de vauvy travailler
dans l'interprétation et soyez en sûr
vous en ferez des chefs-d'oeuvre merci